hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll you may have
heard that one sign of an open
rationally minded thinker is the ability
to change one's mind to have an opinion
and change it to something else in the
face of new arguments or evidence
personally I don't even remember usually
when I change my mind about things one
of the ways my brain works and I don't
think I'm unusual in this is that I
convinced myself that I always believed
that thing that I believe right now even
though I did change my mind
but there's one example where I remember
very vividly in science that I changed
my mind from a strong belief one way to
another and that's in whether or not
Pluto is a planet you may have heard you
may remember where you were when you
first learn the news back in 2006 the
International Astronomical Union got
together and decided that we would no
longer classify Pluto as a planet but
instead as a dwarf planet this caused
outrage across the globe as people
school children and older folks said
look we know what the planets are there
are nine of them and Pluto is one of
them this is you even made it into an
episode of Rick and Morty the animated
feature but they're on Rick and Morty
the reason why puto had gotten demoted
is because it was getting smaller that
the Plutonians were mining their own
central core so that Pluto itself was
shrinking over time
that's not why in the real world Pluto
got demoted it's not that Pluto changed
is that our understanding of the solar
system changed
Pluto didn't get smaller the rest of the
solar system got bigger out there beyond
the orbit of Neptune there's something
called the Kuiper belt which is a
collection of a large number of objects
many many many objects some of them get
pretty big it's only fairly recently
that we discovered that there are a
number of objects in the Kuiper belt
that are comparable in size to Pluto so
basically the choice for astronomers war
was either to expand the solar system to
include all of these new discoveries as
new planets or to demote Pluto from the
ranks of course there's another option
which is the one that I originally
believed which is you could just grand
father Pluto aim right you could say the
planets are the nine planets that we
know about and Pluto discovered in 1930
is the last one we're gonna let into the
club we've known for a long time the
Pluto is small Pluto is smaller than
Earth's moon but the important thing
upon reflection is that Pluto is not
even the most important object in its
orbit around the Sun Pluto's orbit
crosses that of Neptune it's at an angle
it's sort of not that important
dynamically speaking in the solar system
so rationally there was really no reason
to keep Bluto as a planet and exclude
the other ones the IAU the International
Astronomical Union eventually decided to
just invent a new category call them all
dwarf planets if anyone is responsible
for this change in attitude towards the
status of Pluto is today's guest dr.
Michael Brown an astronomer and
colleague of mine at Caltech Mike was
the one who led the team that discovered
these other large Kuiper belt objects
that are now joining Pluto in the dwarf
planet Club he's received a lot of scorn
for being the person who demoted Pluto
but he owns it rather than denies it
Mike's Twitter handle is Pluto killer
and his book is called how I killed
Pluto and why it had it coming
that's actually the book that I read
that finally changed my mind as a
scientist it's important to be rational
to try to understand things to
categorize them properly and when you
face up to the evidence Pluto does not
belong in the planet club these days
Mike is trying to make up for what he
did to the solar system by finding a new
planet he and our colleague konstantin
batygin a Caltech claimed there is
evidence in the motion of known Kuiper
belt objects for a new planet out there
far beyond the orbit of Neptune which
they have dubbed planet 9 just to remind
us that Pluto is not one of the planets
we already have you can make up your own
mind these draw numbers have made up
theirs today we're gonna figure out why
we think the polluter doesn't belong and
what that tells us about the future of
understanding what's going on in our
solar system
so let's go
[Music]
Mike Brown welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks for having me so you're
technically an astronomer but you're in
a planetary sciences department here at
Caltech like what do you tell people you
are when you meet them on an airplane so
I will say if if someone says what do
you do I say I'm an astronomer but my
official title is professor of planetary
astronomy so I get to kind of have it
both ways but I'm an astronomer who
looks at planets in our solar system
yeah you don't look at stars or galaxies
like a real astronomer you know I
they get in the way and I have to
somehow figure out ways to ignore them
but but I look at the real planets how
did you get interested in that what was
it what that's the imagination it is not
what I thought I was going to do and I
when I went into to graduate school to
be an astronomer I I went to Berkeley
for graduate school
and I went to Berkeley because I wanted
to work on the most distant galaxies
known to man and you made a terrible
mistake
yeah so these these most distant
galaxies at the time where the goal was
to find things at a redshift of 3 which
is funny to people who know these days
that like people are finding things I
don't even know how much further away
these days but at the time that was that
was the big quest find things that
redshift of 3 one of the people doing
this the best in the in the world was
high-spin read at Berkeley and so I went
to Berkeley to work with high-spin read
I spend rad had a hobby of looking at
comets in addition to looking at
galaxies and he just he just liked he
I'm not sure why actually his wife
claims that the reason he'd like to look
at comets is because he couldn't tell
the difference between galaxies and
comets they look the same in fact today
we didn't even know right nebulae yeah
well so I back in the day wasn't that
long ago so we did actually but he would
take spectra of comets took the
composition of comets and he he always
tried to get his grad students
interested in studying comets in
addition to galaxies and he could never
get anybody interested because at the
time and it's still sort of this way at
the time in astronomy there is a rank
order of who is the coolest and who is
the least cool and the coolest kids are
the ones who study the very most distant
things that's
what I wanted to do so if you study very
distant galaxies super cool if you study
nearby galaxies you're probably okay if
you study stars and our galaxies you're
kind of a loser and if you study planets
or anything in our solar system like why
are you even there exoplanets are cool
but like planets that are in actual our
solar system yeah so so at the time
there were no known exoplanet so so even
the fact that exoplanets have now have
made nearby things because they're
exoplanets are closer than distant
galaxies so now the the ranking is a
little bit different but at the time if
you study planets you're you're a loser
so he forced his students to study
comets for one summer before they could
look at galaxies because he just wanted
them to you know get some work done for
a hazing ritual yeah so I so I did
mostly I wanted to work on comets but I
worked I mean galaxies it worked on this
comet stuff and then a moderately bright
comet came by at the time and we went up
to the telescope Lick Observatory to
study it and I remember this moment
forever
we were we were looking at comet Austin
I can't remember what year come with
Austin was looking at comet Austin
through the telescope getting a spectrum
it's coming out we're seeing the
composition and I walk out into the dome
of the telescope and I can I can sight
up the barrel of the telescope and I see
the comet there in the sky yeah and that
was it it was like oh my god this this
is not an abstract thing like a distant
galaxy with coordinates that we're
measuring this is that thing in the sky
and and I was I was stuck since then I
have always your heart beat a little bit
it really did so I from my for my thesis
my PhD thesis I studied Jupiter and its
moons and I would be there the telescope
and I would get out my binoculars and
stand outside and look at the moons and
see the same thing I was seeing and it's
just I I love that visceral feeling that
that what I'm studying is actually real
as opposed to this very distant smudge
those are also real by the way less real
they're further ok so yeah you can't see
them almost everything I've studied
these days I studied some pretty faint
things but at the time they were all
bright enough that you could
take out your binoculars and see them
and that was pretty cool and you
mentioned spectra I mean one of the
things that well I was an undergraduate
astronomy major I don't know if you need
to think but I have no degrees in
physics all my PhD investors agree are
both in astronomy all right I forgotten
it all by now but one of the things that
absolutely was drilled into me was the
ability of astronomers to take a
incredibly tiny amount of data and spend
an incredibly elaborate story about what
they were looking at so why don't you
say a little bit about like so we take a
picture of a comet what does that tell
us how do we get information about yeah
so it's the for the studies that we were
doing in particular it's it's the it's
the spectrum you take a the Comets up in
the sky you collect the light from this
the comet you you stick it into a big
elaborate prism and you split it up into
all its colors and all of the chemicals
in the comet in the atmosphere of the
comet and that coma that makes a comment
a comet
each one of them has a different
fingerprint of basically colors that it
emits and so we were we were simply
trying to see what all the the chemicals
were in in that coma
by looking at their very we had a very
very very fine spectrograph it's called
you know elaborate prison where we could
we could really break up the light into
incredible number of colors and we could
really in very detail see not just what
the chemicals were but they slightly
change their characteristics based on
their temperatures and their velocities
and so we could we could map out all
these things just by looking at that one
little spot because these comets are
moving around the Sun and you're
catching them not when they're at their
farthest away but when they're more or
less close to the Sun and yeah so there
because we needed it to be pretty bright
to be able to break up the light into
all those components so the Comets that
people tend to study in detail are ones
that are pretty much the same distance
away from the Sun as the earth is that's
that's when they really start to get the
heat up they their surfaces evaporate
they get all that stuff in the
atmosphere and that's when you can
really study their details and their
dirty snowballs roughly speaking that's
what I remember they are dirty snowballs
and then the interesting question is
what is the dirt and what is the snow
right because it's yes it's mostly water
in the snow and it's mostly
we don't know what it's mostly on the
dirty part but it's a that studying the
other parts of the comet or what's
really done and it's not really snow
there was never a snowfall on the
comment its insights ice yeah yeah so
you moved on though from comments to I
did find it like things well so I that
as my you know my PhD I studied the the
volcanic emissions from Jupiter's moon
Io okay as they exploded off the surface
of Io and then they would go into orbit
around Jupiter and then the magnetic
field of Jupiter would grab ahold of
them and start spitting it around and so
I was studying this elaborate dance of
all these objects that you could do in
the same thing as actually the same
instrument that broke up the light into
very small components that allowed me to
see here's this and here's that and
here's what's going in here was that so
it was just it was it was fantastic
looking all the chemicals that I oh I
always did yo is it really I I can say
both in the same sentence you're
professional okay so yeah so the
volcanoes is huge volcano right on there
a bunch of them a bunch of them yeah
viewing stuff out into the atmosphere
yeah the whole neighborhood of Jupiter
is like a mess with magnetic fields and
radiation and whole life and junk from
IO actually junk from IO is one of the
main components of the the magnetosphere
that's that's going on which would make
it tough to like go visit Jupiter and
hang around the new spaceship this is
actually why when spacecraft go to
Jupiter they usually spend most their
time pretty far away in fact the the
Juno spacecraft that's there right now
it's on this very very very elongated
orbit it comes in really close but then
it goes off super far away and it does
that because you cannot spend that much
time very close because it'll get
smacked basically by stuff that came
from volcanoes on Io ha okay so you
still though studying things that we
know to have existed so Galileo yes yes
that was a long time ago that is true
what made you move on to the further
reaches of the solar system so in while
I was a graduate student at Berkeley the
very first object beyond Neptune since
Pluto was discovered the first first new
Kuiper belt objects 1992 qb1
second is its license plate number
and at the time I remember hearing about
at the time from the discoverer actually
the day before I went public Jane Lew
told me about it she was in an office
right down the hall for me and I thought
oh that's interesting
but you know who cares he's a rock so
yeah ice ball a big deal and very
quickly it became apparent that this
region beyond Neptune was full of stuff
and that it was it's in a sense the most
pristine region of the solar system it's
not pristine but it's the most pristine
it's like these things are cold they've
been they've been in deep freeze since
the beginning in the solar system and
you can study more and more about how
the solar system formed by finding these
very distant things and so I thought
this is this is an interesting thing to
think about but the big change was when
I arrived at Caltech and looking around
at Caltech as an astronomer at Caltech I
suddenly had access to telescopes that I
had never had access to before the the
big telescope at Palomar Observatory the
relatively new at the time Keck
telescopes out on Mauna Kea are big
telescopes that are really good at
seeing faint objects I made a deliberate
decision to stop studying these
relatively bright planetary objects
because I had unique ability to study
these faint ones and I sort of changed
paths entirely and decided to start
studying the outer parts of the solar
system so let's set the stage here what
the solar system looks like maybe have
your planets you have your asteroids you
mentioned the word Kuiper belt like what
is the scale of all these things and
where does the planetary system end and
stuff like yeah so you know we the the
inner part of the solar system most
people would say the inner part of the
solar system is is everything inside the
orbit of Jupiter so we've got Mercury
Venus and Earth and Mars all the line
there and then between Mars and Jupiter
is this big region of relatively small
rocky asteroids the asteroid belt you
know in the asteroid belt is not the
star wars version where you have to
dodge while you're flying through it
there's now every time the spacecraft
goes to the outer solar system they try
desperately to fly near an asteroid
so they can take a picture of an
asteroid and it's hard it's hard to find
them unless you try that's not what the
movies ago no it's it doesn't it's
nothing quite like a dangerous place as
far as yeah so you could you could go
through there a million times and and
miss every asteroid unless you were
trying hard when I was a kid I was
absolutely convinced that it used to be
a planet that got too destroyed somehow
and I still kind of cling to that belief
so apparently astronomers don't believe
that the asteroid belt used to be a
planet no but they but they did believe
that at first so the first asteroid was
discovered January 1st 1801 it was Ceres
and then in quick succession
three more were discovered and you know
imagine how strange this was there were
you could you could look up in the sky
there were the most recent discovery had
been Uranus and Uranus was the first
thing discovered with a telescope the
first you know object that we knew about
in the sky that we didn't know about
before found with the telescope and kind
of blew people's minds
well sorry Galileo and the moons right
yeah okay so there were so that they
were there were moons of things that
were being found that's actually doing
Saturn's moons Herschel discovered them
I can't think of the year that Herschel
discovered but you're absolutely Reynes
is out there all by itself all by itself
and so it actually led people to search
for a new planet
systematically and you know at the time
there was this sort of numerology the
the bodes law that suggested there
should be a planet right about where it
turns out the asteroid belt is because
it's easy to make up numbers that make
you think something might be true and so
people started looking they call
themselves the celestial police and they
started scanning the skies actually the
celestial police did not find the first
asteroid there was an accidental
discovery from of the first one but the
celestial police found many of the well
then the next three so they found three
they found four in quick succession for
maybe four years three years four years
and they all had very similar orbits so
people were looking for a planet at
about this location and they find four
small things okay and that was the the
not unreasonable at the time assumption
like well must have been a planet that
exploded
seamless plausible as exploded yeah
something has blown up yeah so no and
nothing else was found until actually
don't know when the fifth asteroid was
found but it was 1840s I think it was
how many do we know about now Oh 300,000
maybe you know down to the size of a
desk or something you know there's
there's there's tiny things out there
that are found and and now we know that
there was no planet that formed there it
in fact it's the opposite it's that a
planet would have formed there but
Jupiter messed with everything you know
whenever there's anything going on in
the inner solar system it's probably
Jupiter's voice yeah exactly and I think
that there's this a lesson that will
we'll come back to I think you know we
think of the solar system is big the
planets are relatively tiny and we sort
of treat them independently I think in
the mind of an on astronomy mmm yeah but
the lessons are over these millions and
billions of year timescales there's a
lot of influence on what's going on in
different parts of the solar system from
the planets that are there and this fact
that there's a whole bunch of things in
more or less similar orbits between Mars
and Jupiter has to do with gravity and
dynamics and how do butter does things
yeah so it's so it if it hadn't been for
Jupiter all these objects would have
been able to coagulate together to form
a planet but instead Jupiter is so close
by every time an object gets close but
not even really that close to Jupiter it
gets a little tug and its orbit is kind
of perturbed and shaken up so basically
as these things are trying to coagulate
Jupiter comes by and shakes them they
try to coagulate Jupiter shakes I mean
in the end they're never able to form a
planet or the Jovians didn't want the
competitions they destroyed the planet
it's early it's actually possible on we
shouldn't be as close minded the
establishment is having some things here
I've read them so good so that's the
inner so let's that's the inner solar
system and then we get to Jupiter so
Jupiter so then there's the the realm of
the giant planet so Jupiter and Saturn
are the two really big giant planets you
know it's funny people people have a
very poor understanding of the sizes of
planets because mostly they see them
like on kids lunchboxes where they're
all more or less the same as
as you know and pretty close mercury is
a little smaller than Jupiter but not
that much more so Jupiter and Saturn are
huge and so they these are you know so
the distances we measure everything is
in is astronomical units one being the
distance from the earth the Sun is one
astronomical unit Jupiter is at five so
it's five times further from the Sun and
then then the giant planets are nicely
arranged Jupiter's of five Saturn's at
ten Uranus is at twenty it'd be nice of
Neptune we're at 40 but no it's at 30
but no okay close enough so there's
those are pretty easy to remember so
Neptune is the end of this realm of the
giant planets but you're innocent have
to we're actually not nearly as large as
Jupiter and Saturn are they they are I
think you know Uranus and Neptune or
maybe three or four times the physical
size of the earth you know they're
they're big but they're not I didn't
think they were that small yeah they're
really kind of small Jupiter Saturn huge
Jupiter Jupiter is as is 315 I think is
the number of times more massive than
the earth Neptune is about 17 times more
mass than the earth and they're all gas
giants so doesn't mean they're all gas
or there's little rocky core so the big
ones well so this is actually the one of
the prime reasons that the Juno
spacecraft is at Jupiter right now in
orbit around Jupiter is trying to answer
that exact question we think probably
that they all have rocky cores but we
don't know for sure and we're we're
trying to find the answer that with with
these sorts of spacecraft I mean the
Great Red Spot has been on Jupiter for
hundreds of years yeah isn't it do
people think that maybe it's the
reflection of that there's some feature
on the surface of the core no so the
early atmosphere yeah purely atmospheric
the core is the core is tiny the core so
I said that the Jupiter way is about 315
times more than Earth the core might be
15 Earth masses of that so it's really a
very tiny fraction a critical fraction
that actually leads to the formation of
Jupiter itself but but in terms of
what's going on with Jupiter it's
actually a pretty insignificant chunk
going on so that's Jupiter and Saturn is
very much like a slightly smaller
version of Jupiter Uranus and Neptune
are very very different
although we think of them all as gas
giants many astronomers call Uranus and
Neptune ice giants so it'sit's a better
description of Uranus and Neptune or let
me let me step back the a good
description of Jupiter and Saturn is
mostly gas with a little bit of core
right Uranus and Neptune are mostly core
with a little bit of gas okay it's not
like you could stand on their surface
and it's not like they have a solid
surface in the chords this weird
metastable liquid that I understand the
physics of but I don't really even
understand what it means when I say it
so some people say they have that that
they're they're liquid and the interior
not really liquid in the interior but
they're very different from Jupiter's I
never landed on any of these play well
we've sent probes into a probe into
Jupiter it it you know scratch the
tiniest bit of the surface before it was
imploded through the to the pressure of
the United Oracle surface it didn't
actually reach the hour it went and went
in a tiny tiny bit people would love to
send probes into the other ones in
particular Uranus and Neptune would be
fascinating because they're so different
and we know so little about them and
because planets like those seem to be
very common throughout the galaxy and so
it would be very interesting to learn
about what those planets are more like
we you know so you're insane Epton have
been flown by once by Voyager one or two
I forget which one went one of them
diverted so it could do a flyby of the
rings of Saturn and and to do that it
had to go and it had to basically go up
out of the solar system and never go by
anymore
but one of them went by earrings nepeta
and that's it we we know very little
about these planets which means there's
a lot of room for young astronomers to
grow up and study these nothing we don't
know right yeah okay and then it was
always true about Pluto that it was a
little weird if you saw a picture of the
solar system that was a little bit more
accurate the orbit was way more
eccentric these planets have circular
orbits right ludos in a very strong
ellipse if tilted compared to everything
else and it's not even its own orbit it
crosses inside Neptune occasionally yeah
so weird so I remember before we
understood
Pluto's place and the rest of the
Soler's
it really was just considered sort of
this oddball at the edge of the solar
system no one really knew why I was
there how it got there didn't really
make any sense but everyone was like
well I guess I was found kind of by
accident like they were looking for it
yeah so well so this is this is this is
how the whole problem with Pluto and
planet hood started is that people were
looking for Planet X now when you say
Planet X people just think that means
anything out there that you don't know
about but Planet X it was an actual
thing there was a prediction of a
specific planet from Percival Lowell
Percival Lowell had letters for all of
his predictions and X just happened to
be the number the one that he was
predicting and and the reason he thought
that there was a planet out there is
because he looked at the orbits of
Uranus and Neptune and they appeared to
be being tugged by something and of
course this is how Neptune itself was
found and so it the day that Neptune
Neptune was found in 1845 astronomers
everywhere were like oh wow the very a
predicted a planet based on
perturbations and dude got super famous
I'm gonna do the same and so I mean
literally from that day people have been
saying I predict a planet I predict a
planet I predict the planet every single
one of them has been wrong until very
recently but Lowell had predicted that
there was this planet and set off to
find it and he he actually said that one
of the very first times he looked for it
he sent a team up to Mount Wilson right
here above us here in Pasadena you know
you can look out the window and see the
telescopes the big telescopes didn't
exist yet this was like something like
1916 there was a small station up there
and he said it he said go look in this
location and they took a big
photographic plate of the sky right
there and brought it back down and he
looked at it and like
and I don't see this giant planet that
I'm looking for so he eventually passed
away but he had founded Lowell
Observatory with one of the goals was to
find his Planet X that he predicted and
that's that's why Clyde Tombaugh was
hired off the farm to come take pictures
of the sky looking for this planet Clyde
Tombaugh took a couple pictures and and
realized that he didn't know what a
planet looked like because he just
looked it looks like a star right
Percival Lowell thought that it was
gonna be big so he thought he would know
that it would it looked like it would be
a big spot instead of a smaller Clyde
Tombaugh said you know I don't know and
so he realized that you take a picture
one night and you take a picture the
next night and all the stars and all the
galaxies are in the same place planets
move so we did that so we took
photographic plates looked for things
that moved and very quickly and very
close to the predicted location of
Planet X he found Pluto there's a little
dot moving and you know this is I think
about this a lot because this is one of
the ways that science can get it wrong
at first and then eventually correct
itself there was a prediction of a giant
planet at this location something was
found at this location therefore it must
be that thing so if you go to the New
York Times headlines of the when they
announced the discovery ninth planet
discovered the solar system blah blah
blah and in right below the headline new
planet 4 billion miles from the Sun I
think that's the right number I can't do
mile as well but that's 4 billion miles
from the Sun possibly as large as
Jupiter and meets predictions and that's
the meets predictions is where science
can get itself in trouble so so because
it was a prediction people and so people
thought at first that Pluto was as big
as Jupiter that is only wrong by a
factor of 250,000 but it but it you know
if you think it's as big a Jupiter if it
were as big as Jupiter it would be no
question that it's that it's a planet
and its own right it took a long time
for that that mass of Pluto to slowly
work its way down to the realization now
that it's like it's it's a tiny fraction
it's smaller than our moon and it's a
tiny fraction of the mass of the moon
because it's just a little ice ball so
it's in the grand scheme of things in
the solar system it's pretty small and
then there's this thing called the
Kuiper belt which has a kind of
interesting history of its own right
like it wasn't discovered by Kuiper it
was vaguely predicted by Kuiper so it
was named after Kuiper I think this is a
long-standing and good tradition in
astronomy that the it was basically
named by those people who found 1992 qb1
which was I would say the second Kuiper
belt object after Pluto being the first
but we didn't know at the time and they
said possible Kuiper belt object and
they named it after pepper because
Kuiper had written a paper that
suggested that possibly there is this
belt of ice balls out beyond Pluto they
said at the time out beyond Pluto that's
a source one of the sources of comets
that come into the inner solar system
the the Kuiper paper was really nearly a
throwaway it was not a very detailed
calculation or a really much of
prediction but it was you know Kuiper is
a large figure in planetary astronomy so
I'm actually very happy that it's that
it was named for him there people who
argue oh that was the inappropriate name
it should be called the
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah but it's not
should be as the the discoverers named
it and I think that's I respect the
naming of the discovery absolutely and
it's different than the Oort cloud which
we've heard about in terms of where
comets come from also so why do we need
more cloud and a Kuiper belt because
there are two flavors of common one
flavor of Comet comes in basically in
the disk of the solar system and we see
a lot of comets that are that are
basically on the same types of orbits as
all the planets are tilted by a little
bit but not very much and then we see a
second set of comets that come from
everywhere all directions equally with
no no preference those come from the
Oort cloud and cloud because it's it's
this uniform very distant cloud around
the Sun and the Kuiper belt belt because
it's a it's a
a Taurus of material out beyond Neptune
just like the asteroid belt is mostly
stuff that's in the plane of the solar
system the Kuiper belt is the same way
and are these really two clearly
distinct populations do they kind of
blend in well so this is a an active
question that we would like to know the
answer to they they probably come from
the same original source but we don't we
don't know very much about the
transition from the Kuiper belt to the
Oort cloud I used to think I did and now
I know less than I used to science yeah
it's true so so the Kuiper belt is as
we're continuing our tour of the solar
system so Neptune it's the the edge of
the what we know of as the the realm of
the giant planets and then out beyond
Neptune there is this belt of icy
material if it is that is completely
analogous to the asteroid belt it's not
the same as the asteroid belt it's icy
instead of rocky but the reasons for it
the way it behaves are exactly the same
the reason there is a Kuiper belt
instead of a planet beyond Neptune is
because Neptune messed with stuff
Neptune did the same thing to the Kuiper
belt that Jupiter did to the asteroid
belt there would have been a planet
beyond Neptune had Neptune not formed
fast and then shook up everything out
there and didn't let it form into a
planet so there's no planet out there
there's just a belt of debris basically
that never never got a chance to form a
planet and some of the moons and things
of the planets we know about in the
solar system might have been captured
from the Kuiper belt
so the movies of all hypotheses yeah so
the moon's the moon's that you generally
know of like the big ones and like the
Galilean satellites Titan around Saturn
those all formed in place so those are
all those are all part of the the
planetary system but but all of the
giant planets have what's called
irregular satellites regular meaning
that the regular satellites are in the
plane of the planet there they rotate in
the same direction as the rotation of
the planet so they're they're all part
of that initial disk but they all have
you know it almost sounds like the Oort
cloud that I was talking about they all
have these clouds of small moons around
them that are just going in all kinds of
crazy directions and those are
absolutely captured from the Kuiper belt
or from the
region where the Kuiper belt got started
to begin with some of them were probably
probably captured early on before there
was even a Kuiper belt but it's the same
stuff it's the same icy things that are
out there okay all right good so I think
that more or less finishes our tour
we're able to catch up where Jane Lew I
think it was had discovered a new this
new yeah object and then what year was
that 1992 that's why it gets that
license-plate number of 1992 qb1 okay
and is that in a similar orbit to Pluto
or similar size it's about 200
kilometers across so it's small compared
to Pluto which is about 2,400 kilometers
across and it's it's does not have the
same sort of orbit as Pluto it's a
little further away further out it's a
it's a little bit more circular than
Pluto is what we now know is that there
are several different classes of objects
in the Kuiper belt there are many many
many many objects with orbits just like
Pluto and an orbit just like Pluto I
don't mean it's exactly the same orbit I
mean it is it comes inside the orbit of
Neptune it's tilted by you know anywhere
from 0 to 30 degrees it's elongated like
Pluto is elongated if I if I if I drew a
diagram of all those objects and put
Pluto's orbit in there too you could not
distinguish so there's one flavor that's
like that they're a little bit further
out there's a flavor of ones that are
like this 1992 qb1 they're a little bit
more circular a little bit more they
don't cross the orbit of Neptune across
to cross the orbit of Neptune and to
live you have to be on a very special
orbit on a resonance it's called so
Pluto and all of these other objects
that are called blue Tino's Latino yeah
that I think is a good name to all of
those objects Neptune they go around two
times the Sun they go around the Sun two
times precisely for every three times
Neptune goes around the Sun so they're
locked into this very precise dance that
they are through complicated
gravitational mechanism they're forced
to be locked into that they can't escape
it but by being locked into that they
never come close to Neptune so they're
there every time they cross the orbit of
Neptune Neptune is on the other side son
so actually Pluto
comes closer to Uranus than it ever does
to Neptune crosses now and it's another
example of this sort of gentle but
crucially important dynamical influence
that the planets have on each other and
random objects in the solar system can't
be in any old orbit there's certain
orbits that are happy to for a planet to
be in yeah and good so but this is uh
this discovery of more Kuiper belt
objects this is somewhat your fault or
in Celtx vault anyway for giving you
telescope yeah something so uh so yeah
so this is when I when I started here
there were boy I probably when I started
as a young naive assistant professor
there might have been a hundred known
Kuiper belt objects okay which is you
know going from from one in nineteen
ninety to two-hundred was a lot of work
for a lot of people and I and I realized
this is this is going to be big I want
to I want to get into this and so I
started doing a couple projects studying
the known objects and what I really got
excited about was the realization that
that it was very clear it was it was
obvious to people who had looked
carefully at it that there would be some
large Kuiper belt objects out there they
they might like large I mean Pluto size
bigger than Pluto size we didn't know
but that that Pluto was not an outlier
it just happened to be the one that was
found first by Clyde Tombaugh but there
there should be other things very much
less like Pluto the hard thing is that
finding objects that the small number of
large objects is a lot harder to find
than the large number of small objects
the the the analogy I used to always
make when I was doing this is that if
you you know if you go out into the
ocean and you get a big net and you
scoop it you'll find a ton of small fish
but you're probably not gonna get a
whale okay finding a whale is a lot
harder that analogy you you have to go
sail all around so we didn't have a good
way of you know we didn't have a big net
astronomers of the time we're really
good and they were they're just
developing these electronic detectors
this the CCD that everybody now has in
their their cameras we're pretty new
then and they're pretty small if you
remember your first digital camera
might have been one of those like 380 by
500 pixels that was you know tiny
compared to what we have now astronomers
were the same way we could we could only
look at a tiny area of the sky but these
things were so good this is late 90s
late 90s so if you wanted to cover large
swaths of the sky you couldn't with
these these digital detectors so I
actually I did one of the very last
projects I think with photographic
plates that I'm probably the youngest
astronomer to ever do a project using
photographic plates that might actually
be a true statement I'm not I'm not a
hundred percent sure that's true but I
used this old telescope at Palomar
Observatory which had been built at the
same time as the big 200-inch telescope
it's the the 48 inch Schmidt telescope
had been built basically to take
widefield pictures of the sky to help
the 200-inch know where to look right
what was interesting in the sky and
there are these famous at the time the
these these famous sky pictures that you
could go to any astronomical library and
they would all have drawers that you
would pull out and get the the Palomar
prints for that point of the sky and you
could see what was in the sky now you
can get them all online and it's less
fun but at the time if you were gonna
look at something you would go library
you'd pull out the print you would take
a picture of it because you're about to
go to the telescope when you need to
make sure you were looking at the right
thing they had these you know Polaroid
cameras designed specifically to you
Mountain it here and you could take a
picture and you'd walk back with your
picture of where you were looking in the
sky you're finding chart we called him
now you know kids these days they just
look on there they're through this and
their Twitter yeah but it was it was it
was pretty fun back then so it was built
to do that sort of thing and it was
nobody was doing things with
photographic plates anymore so it was
spending a lot of time just sitting
around doing nothing I don't like it
when telescopes sit around and do
nothing makes me very upset so I
realized that I could use it to take
pictures of vast areas of the sky the
disadvantage is photographic plates are
not very sensitive compared to digital
detectors and so in a the
the the differences in about a half an
hour of exposing a photographic plate on
the sky I can see things about the same
faintness as I can now from the same
telescope that's still being used but
with digital detectors in about 30
seconds okay so so it was a lie you're
the last one gainfully inefficient but
that means I could cover big areas of
sky so so I spent a couple years doing
that and I and and just sort of caught
the bug like I really was pretty
convinced that we were gonna find
something big you just hate bring this
guy you're just looking all over the
place we didn't have enough time to
paper the whole sky and so we had to
pick word of paper and so we went we did
a swath right along the the clip take
the plane of the the planets and we know
if we look up in the sky and you see
where the moon is and where Mars is and
where Jupiter is they make this line
across the sky that's the line across
the sky that we looked at okay and we
looked a little bit of a little below
and went along there and spent three
years and it was pretty exciting because
we found not a thing
zero literally zero there was there were
no objects in the sky bright enough that
we could find them in that part of the
survey that we did turns out had we wait
so I tell you we looked at the ecliptic
and we looked a little bit above and a
little below had we gone 50 percent more
below or 50 percent more above we would
have found things back in 1998 okay but
we didn't know that at the time it turns
out the bright copper belt objects are
preferentially above and below the
ecliptic not on the ecliptic who knew so
we didn't find anything but but I just
it just really reinforced to me that
this is something that you just we just
needed to do somebody needs to go out
there and cover the whole sky
photographic plates were a little bit of
a pain but but it this was right about
the time when the the digital detectors
were getting better and bigger they
weren't great but you could start you
could kind of string a bunch of them
together it's kind of like you know
taking a hundred of those 580 by 300
camera
and and mounting them all on a big board
and pointing about the sky I mean it was
his sort of kludgy as that yeah but in
the end we could cover inefficiently
still but we could cover vast parts of
the sky and so it took about six more
years seven more years to cover the
whole sky but we covered the whole sky -
much better than we could do with the
photographic plates and slowly as we
were covering the whole sky we would
find we found a lot of moderately big
Kuiper belt objects I'll say moderately
big to me is a 500 kilometer object in
the sky which is kind of cool you you
know you're sitting there looking and
you're in your office looking at the
images from the night before and
suddenly you see this thing that's a big
chunk of ice that no human has ever seen
before and he literally billions of
miles away yeah it's pretty hanging out
in the middle I still get a charge every
time I find one of these new ones but
but every once in a while and actually
more as we get got further and further
off of the ecliptic there would be one
that you would you know you're just
looking through the data and you'd be
like oh oh oh and you know I would do
quick calculations of how big it was how
far away what was going on and it was
pretty cool because we would find it
started out we found one that was half
the size of Pluto we thought that was
pretty good that's pretty good we didn't
know how big it was at the time we we
thought maybe was gonna be bigger than
Pluto but we've learned later is about
half the size Pluto it was the biggest
new thing that had been found at the
time it was the largest new object that
had been found since I think it still is
true the largest object found in the
solar system since 1845 ok well other
than Pluto I guess large oh that's when
we found air I was felt like I used to
say that phrase what was I talking about
I was talking about Eris when a founders
which is lighter and it's not actually
the largest so I was wrong but so at the
time 1845 it was like the the it was the
largest objects found since Pluto
how about thing that's pretty good that
was good and we found you know once time
went on we'd find one that was slightly
bigger like 3/4 the size of Pluto they
just they just kept stacking up and it
just by chance we found the smaller ones
first and the bigger ones next and then
one of the last ones we found was in
fact eros eros was this one that
I remember seeing it on my screen when I
first saw it and it's it's it was moving
very slowly across the screen and it was
really bright and my reaction was we're
all good what did I do wrong this time
because you know 90% of your best
discoveries yes yeah yeah maybe 95 maybe
99 percent I mean I make a lot of really
exciting discoveries and most of them
I've had some really great theoretical
ideas too
yeah so same thing so I was like what
did I do it's it's moving slowly our
typical sequence was we would take an
image every hour and a half we would
take three images over the course of
three hours and see how fast the things
were moving so I thought you know what
what if I just screwed up and I
accidentally took them every 10 minutes
and I see this thing not moving very
much it's because it's actually an
asteroid really close by moving fast
that's why it's bright what did I do
wrong I went and checked everything I'm
like well that actually is right oh that
was right - oh that's right - and I was
like it's real
Oh so I called it my wife and I said I
just found a planet because it was
obviously as big as Pluto yeah and if
Pluto is a planet right it's pretty
clear that this thing was a planet Eris
the Eris he didn't name it that I did at
the time I did not name it that because
it didn't we we had code names for all
the things that we found at the time
that we would talk about just because we
needed you know the first thing that it
was called was the the name that the
computer gave it which was so I can't
believe I can't even remember this one
anyway some string of letters and
numbers most of which used to mean a lot
to me and now I can't remember but we
gave it code name zina which one
reserved for something something bigger
than or your princess like thing yeah
something that was I'm soaked you know
what the idea being that people had
always talked about Planet X I wanted an
X I thought you know be nice to have an
X I wanted to have it you know good
mythological name and so okay so it's TV
mythology but let Pluto was named after
owed you know a cartoon dog so that
seemed no content that's not actually
true but it's it's mostly true and then
there were you know there were there
were not enough
female planet names and so I thought
good what if you wanted a X mythological
X female name choices are limited you
can't good letter you cannot do better
it wasn't awesome
we found a satellite there was an
obvious name for the satellite satellite
was Gabrielle so that's what we called
it for the first the the time while we
were still studying at before we were we
were working on our papers to announce
it to the world by the time it got
announced it still didn't have a name so
I told I believe I told one reporter
that we called it Xena and that story
got out and everybody now knows the lead
right there for many years it was mostly
known as as Xena or the other official
license plate was 2003 you be three one
three that was the International
Astronomical unions license plate number
clearly the stuffed shirts at the
International Islamic Lee Union I'm not
gonna let you get away with Xena as a
long term name for an important
celestial object yeah yeah probably not
although it's an L terrace so notes eros
which is have to say a fantastic name
it's a good so we didn't get to name it
they they they held off on allowing us
to name it until I could decide what it
was right there were some people who
were pushing very hard that it be called
a planet when we announced it we said
10th planet because I figured I don't
even at the time I did I did not think
Pluto deserved be a planet and so I
didn't actually believe the arastoo's
ever be a planet but I'd like look if
you guys are gonna call Pluto planet I'm
gonna call this planet and the worst
that can happen is you can say no it's
not and then Pluto doesn't get to be
planet either so I you know it's win-win
for me so we call it we call it the
tenth planet there were other people who
were very adamant that it should be
classified as a planet and other people
were like no way that's ridiculous
and we just got to hang out and watch
the arguments go but it meant that we
couldn't name it because if it was a
planets well nobody knows how different
and it's yeah if it's just a regular
Kuiper belt object there's ways to name
it so so look when Pluto was officially
relabeled uh yeah we're playing it not a
planet billions of hearts were broken
yeah people got very upset you're you're
considered to be a bad person because of
all this and yet you kind of revel in
that you don't back down
you lean into it if they say today yeah
yeah what it what is the best sales
pitch for saying no we shouldn't call
these things planets or at least we
shouldn't call Pluto a planet why can't
we just let Pluto be a planet and call
these other things post Plutonian
objects or something like that so so you
will often hear arguments from
astronomers who are tired of talking
about this that it doesn't matter
Pluto is Pluto no matter what you call
it bla bla bla it's semantics it doesn't
matter and and I get what they're trying
to say but I actually disagree
completely with the statement that this
is just semantics it doesn't matter it's
not semantics though the word planet the
word that you use is semantics but it's
but it's classification right and
classification is what we do as
scientists to try to understand
phenomena in whatever field we're
studying and bad classification leads to
a lack of understanding of what you're
going on you you could be somebody who
studies birds and you decide to classify
them all and you might classify them as
you know seabirds and and birds that
live here and birds at burrow in the
ground and all these things and you know
you would study them in different ways
than that because or you could be
scientist who studies birds and you
could say I'm gonna study them all the
ones that have blue on their heads and
you know that's a classification and
it's a perfectly valid classification it
just not doesn't mean very much latch on
to anything it does allowed there eight
world doesn't late lead you to ask any
important questions and so when you look
at the solar system and you think about
a classification in the solar system the
classification should lead you to the
important questions so if so if you had
the eight planets plus plus Pluto as a
planet
the main question you would ask about
the solar system is what the heck is
Pluto tweet there it doesn't it doesn't
you you can't ask any questions about
because planet the word is the
classification it is sort of meaningless
there are other people who suggested
that you should have all round things
should be planets which would include
Pluto and Eris and 200 other objects in
the Kuiper belt the moon
the moon many moons so there there are
many things and and it's true they are
different because the the being round
means you have enough gravity that you
have pulled yourself into a sphere which
is very different and so the question
you would ask yourself about the
difference between round things and not
round things is why are there round
things that seems like the obvious
question well I just told you it's
gravity we know the answer to that
actually if if instead you classify the
solar system and if you were to say
there are four terrestrial planets rocky
planets Mercury Venus Earth Mars there
are four giant planets already maybe two
giant planets and two ice giants Jupiter
Saturn Uranus Neptune between Mars and
Jupiter between the terrestrials and the
giant planets there's an asteroid belt
beyond Neptune there's a tie per belt
even further out there's a Nord cloud
that leads to profound questions and the
profound question the obvious question
is why and that why is the main question
that we as planetary scientists are
trying to answer how did the solar
system get to be the way that it is and
by classifying it correctly you you are
led to that question and but and by not
you know we as scientists would still
ask the right questions but I still feel
like it's a public disservice to pretend
that we're gonna call all these other
things planet it doesn't it doesn't help
people understand what the solar system
is like it I would like people to
understand what the solar systems like
and before we forget what is the
definition of a planet because the
definition I mean there are people like
God just stupid definition and like okay
yes it is a stupid definition the fact
that there is a definition is is stupid
in astronomy I mean can you think of
anything else have a phenomenon in
astronomy and object type in astronomy
in the sky for which there is a
definition that somebody has to check is
this value a planet has a three-part
definition that you have to fulfill all
three parts and the lawyers can argue
about whether you lay down this tell us
through the eye you says you have to be
around so that's the last one you have
to be an orbit around Sun so this says
people get confused by this one - yeah
the definition of a planet in the solar
system is that you have to be in orbit
around Sun I mean I felt part of the
motivation for going through these
arguments was that we thought we would
be discovering planets elsewhere the
only motivation for this argument is to
deal with Pluto ok literally that if
there is no other reason for this
definition of planet and then we know
how to be dealt with one way or the
other so the definition is in orbit
around the Sun round big enough to be
round and then the third part kicker
which is where all the arguments come
about and and it's phrased terribly but
it's I understand what they're trying to
say it has to clear its orbit clear its
orbit of other stuff of other stuff
right so the you know instantly the
amateur astronomical lawyers say well so
Neptune is not a planet because Pluto
and it's you know yes it's because it's
because the the it's it's not because
empty is not a planet it's because the
definition is both poorly worded and a
bad idea to have to begin with what so
what the but there I mean what they're
trying to say is that the planets are
the gravitationally dominant things out
there and it's super easy to make a
calculation of something that you would
call gravitational dominance and see
that the eight planets are incredibly
different from everything else in the
solar system they are big dominant
bodies that kick around everybody else
you know you could say the argument is
the the planets all the things that are
not planets are sort of flitting in and
out of the orbits of all the planets
getting kicked around by the planets and
the planets are the ones doing the kick
in and nobody kicks planets around right
that's that's a pretty good definition
and so by this definition we have the
eight planets and Pluto is just one of
the various dwarf planets in the Kuiper
belt and as you sort of alluded to
alternatively the only sensible
alternative that didn't sort of just
make Pluto a thing all by itself would
be to have dozens of planets and
hundreds hundreds in beauty to discover
of many many plans yeah this is what's
what I always find funny when people
like you just hey Pluto so you don't
want them to be
like dude do you know that if if I used
your definition I would be the biggest
planet discover in human history do you
know that and the answer's no they don't
know that you just don't want to be like
someone asked me back in that first year
when Xena was still being generally
called the tenth planet I was doing an
interview and somebody said you know
what does it feel like to have
discovered the tenth planet I stopped
and I thought about it and I said you
know how it feels it feels fraudulent
you know Impostors in it no I wouldn't
even say it's imposter syndrome I'd say
it actually feels fraudulent and that
it's soso Herschel you know opened up
his brand-new fancy telescope pointed to
the sky and found Uranus this thing
that's 17 times more massive than the
earth you know big chunk of the solar
system the very a did calculations on
how the orbits were going realized it
was something else out there had someone
pointed telescope and boom there was
Neptune those are those are significant
things in our solar system and if you
removed any of them our solar system
would be a different place if you
removed eros or Pluto or any of these
other objects the solar system exactly
the same place these are these are you
know they don't define the solar system
in the same way so it just it really did
feel fraudulent to pretend that this was
a major part of the solar system and you
really had to pretend if you wanted to
call it the tenth planet but the good
news is now we're basically done right
we have the Kuiper belt we have eight
planets and there's no more planets ever
to be found
we're not older sister yeah so we're not
done so you're saying there could be
other I landed so here's what I'm saying
there is at least one other planet I'm
not saying could be both I'm not saying
might be I am I am as close to a hundred
percent convinced as you can be in this
business that we have found
gravitational evidence for a ninth
planet if you recall I am about the five
hundred and seventy fifth person to say
this since 1845 it's an
long distinguished lineage yes it's not
distinguished it is really scary to say
this it was it was scary for a for me
and my colleague who came up with idea
konstantin batygin he and I came up with
this idea a couple years ago and we were
very reluctant you know we started doing
the calculations we started seeing what
we seeing and we're like god it really
really kind of makes sense it's a planet
like we do not want to be that 547
person saying we we predict a planet and
we're right and everybody else was wrong
but here's the interesting thing is that
we predict a planet and we're right and
everybody else is wrong well let's just
pause for a moment before getting to the
evidence that you're right I mean I want
to just say again or highlight the this
way that science works I mean not only
do we look for evidence and so forth but
we have prior beliefs right and part of
those prior beliefs are colored by
history and what has happened kinda
salutely and so rather than you and
Constantine just running out and saying
hey maybe there's a planet you say look
we all know that this has been claimed
before we should be extremely cautious
and really make sure the I's are dotted
in the T's are crossed we also knew that
there were no other planets I was in
graduate school when the final nail was
put in the coffin of Planet X I should
have mentioned this when we were talking
about the discovery of Pluto and the
perturbations and all this stuff is in
the end the reason that Percival Lowell
thought there was a Planet X is because
some of the early observations of
planetary positions were not exactly
right and and he didn't have the precise
mass of Uranus and Neptune and we didn't
have those until Voyager flew by uranus
and neptune so at the final neptune
flyby
we got the precise mass of Neptune and
we did all those calculations of where
the planets are and they're where
they're supposed to be so there is no
planet done with perturbation and I move
that in in graduate school that paper
came out and we all knew there were no
new planets to be found and to think
otherwise was heresy yeah and so of
course there are no new planets and so
this is this this lead when when Colleen
and I first started
looking at these phenomenon it was to
prove that there wasn't a planet right
so what kind of phenomena do you look at
so it's so it's one specific thing that
we eventually found it took us a while
it's that if you look at the most
distant objects in the Kuiper belts so
most the Kuiper belt objects are in
these kind of either kind of circular
ish orbits a little outside of Neptune
or maybe a mildly elongated like like
Pluto but some of them actually are on
hugely elongated orbit and orbits and go
out go out 1020 times further than the
orbit of Neptune and then come back so
they're on these these big elipses like
this if you look at the ones that go the
farthest we realized something
unexpected which is the ones that go the
farthest are preferentially lined up in
a particular way the direction that
they're going when they go out the
farthest is a specific direction there's
no reason that should be so where the
aliens put them when they left there so
even if the aliens even if the aliens
put them there they would very quickly
untangle themselves so each of the
objects in the in the whole solar system
but in particular these distant ones
their orbits change over time and they
they precess is what it's called the
direction of their orbits changes over
you know couple tens to hundreds of
millions time period and so all these
objects are like hands on a clock that
are moving at different speeds and we
happen to look up and they're all
aligned and so it could be you just
happen to look up when they're all
aligned or there's something else going
on and so we sort of split into my job
was to decide whether or not it could be
that they just happen to be all aligned
and it was a kind of sentence and
Constantine started doing calculation
that he's starting math if he actually
started out by like writing equations on
his board and he's like well what do you
think about this I'm like it's like the
Greek letter those are my favorite and
so we we really were trying to figure
out what could have done this we know a
planet could do it you see that and
you're like oh my god must be a planet
that's kind of the last 150 years
because of the D symbol
to how these trans-neptunian objects are
sort of there's certain places they
could fit in without being disturbed by
that's exactly right you're saying is
simply exactly right and we didn't know
the details but we kind of knew like
yeah we get that there must be some some
gravitational perturbation that it'll
make them it'll work we know that let's
like of course that works but that's
that's a crazy thing to jump to
initially so let's figure out what's
really going on because it's not a
planet and we tried really hard to make
it not be a planet yeah and there's
nothing else there is no other way to
make those objects line up the way that
they do and the story got more
convincing over time so the the
convincing aspect of it so so this has
been two and a half years now our paper
has been out planet nine Planet nine as
we called it the time you secretly in
the back of your mind have the name you
want to get no no I am suspicious
suspicious but I'm superstitious but
definitely suspicious too I'm
superstitious enough to do feel like if
you really start to think about a name
you will not find okay and so I really I
honestly do not have a name which is
pretty amazing to have blocked that part
of my brain so I'll do this so it's a
planet 9 I you know we did have a
nickname like we have nicknames for
everything we the nickname was fatty ok
at the time spelled with a pH and it was
because that was gonna that was the ELSA
when I had a daughter she had a nickname
before she was born I seem to make a
habit of that and we had we had one
picked out in case it was a boy it was
gonna be fatty because that's an old
family name of mine is Jehosaphat there
were many jehosophat's and we always
talked about naming our son Jehoshaphat
but we would call him fatty because I
just thought that and and we would make
sure that he was like a jazz saxophonist
because he'd be like fatty Brown doesn't
that sound pretty good night yeah yeah
so what that was what we called Planet
nine at first but eventually Planet nine
was such a good name that we just kept
with Planet nine so two and a half years
also is a little poke to people who
think that Pluto's that was totally
unintentional I promised two and a half
years so one of the things that always
happens in astronomy sure in physics
everything else is that
theorists are really good at explaining
anything oh yeah yeah so if you felt
differently yeah and if you said oh no
I'm sorry I didn't mean that I actually
found that instead like oh okay then I
can explain that too so there I mean
theories are good that's their job
so we knew that as soon as we published
both the observations that these things
are lined up and our hypothesis of
planet 9 very quickly there would be
papers coming up with alternative
explanations alternative physics and we
were curious what they were gonna be
because we couldn't come up with any and
in two and a half years there are zero
and that baffles me that no one has come
up with another way to make that
alignment
I mean Dark Matter cosmic strings aliens
black holes I have a dozen yeah but I
write that paper okay so it has to
actually point at level of that's
actually what does it work
yeah so no I always get the explanations
as like what if it's yeah yeah but but
real physics really working okay I've
seen no explanation so the one potential
explanation and one part that that we
still worried about is the idea that it
was just a random coincidence and not
only a random coincidence but a random
coincidence can be helped along by some
sort of bias in your observations and
there there are many ways that these
observations could have been biased you
can imagine that if you if you're saying
that all of your objects are lined up in
one particular way
well what if that's the only place you
do that for example I mean that would be
an extreme version of the bias but but
we worried about that and it turns out
to be very difficult to do that
calculation right and it has taken us in
fact two and a half years to do that
calculation right and I just finished
the paper on the final calculation this
morning literally Mazel Tov and and the
answer is the probability that it's just
due to chance taking into account all
the biases of all the observations and
everything else is a 0.1% point one four
percent I think so means as possible as
things happen but it it's a small number
yeah so so here's what I say and
paper I say look you don't have to
believe in Planet nine I'll punch you
but you don't have to clean an attitude
but the effect is real and if you if you
don't believe in Planet nine there needs
to be another explanation for right and
so why don't you go look for it well so
we are looking for it okay so I've spent
the two-and-a-half years has been both
understanding those biases because
understand the biases is critical to
then using the observations to predict
where it is so as of right now now that
I understand the biases I have a very
tight prediction of the orbit of Planet
nine in the sky do you know where it
should be so I know the path that its
orbit traces out in the sky and that is
not the same as where it should be that
is where it should be except that I
don't know where you know along the path
when it should be yeah so so the bad
news is were not as good as Lovera a
very a said there's a planet it's right
there and they literally looked one
night and found it it was right at the
very I said it was I got a little lucky
he had a couple things going for him one
is he could make some assumptions like
it's a circular orbit in the plane of
the solar system ours is definitely not
a circular orbit and it's actually not
in the plane of the solar system it's
tilted by by you know 20 30 degrees okay
and so does it per turbine empty it does
not perturbed Neptune it's so far out is
its orbit far away it's it's not a
circular orbit it's an eccentric orbit
centric and it's average distance away
is about 500 au member of Neptune was 30
so it's nearly 20 times further away
than Neptune it has no effect on Neptune
or even the the relatively nearby Kuiper
belt objects the only thing that affects
are these very distant ones that go out
into that realm and so they go out and
into where it is and get a find how big
is planets so now we know it's it's
right around seven times the mass of the
earth might be six might be five might
be eight but it's not it's not that much
different than that so seven times mass
the earth is is again Neptune is about
seventeen so it's smaller than Neptune
bigger than the earth
probably it's like Neptune and then it's
a mostly it's it's an ice giant it's a
it's mostly a core a sort of liquid
Ecore surrounded by by gas so it's way
bigger than the Death Star for example
it's it could swallow the Death Star
quite easily because I mean you must be
thinking why is there such a thing out
there why is it in the wrong orbit yeah
that's so far away so we think we know
that we we have ideas so the idea that
there's an object out there is agnostic
as to how it got there you know so
what's our evidence for its existence
its solid then we just get to make up
stories on how it could have gotten
there interestingly as soon as we
figured out that it was it was something
like seven earth masses ten earth masses
and on this eccentric orbit Constantine
and I both just the same light bulb went
off on our heads at the same time it's
like oh I know where it came from like
yep me too and the answer is ten earth
masses is a special mass in the solar
system ten earth masses is as we've
talked about the mass of the cores of
the giant planets Constantine and I
actually had written this paper six or
seven or eight years ago now about what
would happen in the solar system if
instead of four giant planets you start
out with five giant planets in the
regular giant planet region and the
answer is nearly all the time one of
those giant planets gets destabilized
gets a little too close to Jupiter and
gets tossed out and we were interested
in how that affects the outer solar
system and everything else and we didn't
really want once it got tossed out we
never worried about it so the solar
system is full in some sense planet wise
planet wise yeah so you can't stick new
ones inside where the old ones are and
if you try they they are most likely PD
ejected there's no reason why there
should have only been four cores for
them there should have been actually
many many cores for them so probably
they were cores being tossed out all the
time and we never really thought about
what happens when they get tossed out
the idea that one gets tossed out and
then gets is there's still a little bit
of a waving of a magic wand that has to
happen because it has to then get
stabilized in the outer part of the
solar system and not come back in and
not go back out and so that's
we think that happens when the Sun is
formed in a giant cluster of other stars
so we think we know how that be well you
know our hypothesis is that that's how
it happens but it all kind of makes
sense
it fits perfectly doesn't mean it's true
but it but it's the idea that there was
a core that got ejected and recaptured
is so uncontroversial that you know when
you suggest that to theorists working on
the solar system like oh yeah sure yeah
that's what yeah sure and once it's out
there it is planned at 9:00
sometimes perturbed Kuiper belt objects
and turn them into comments the
government absolutely and it does
something really interesting to them it
does that by twisting their orbits
instead of just perturbing them and
throwing them in it slowly perturbed and
so things that used to be in more or
less the same plane as the solar system
get their orbits twisted by about 90
degrees and so they're plunging into the
solar system and back out again and then
it drives them into the into the Sun in
past Neptune and the the reason the the
transition that Constantine and I took
from thinking this was a cute theory
that could explain things it's easy to
come up with theories that explain
things but you don't believe them most
the time when we started believing it is
when we realized that we were predicting
these these orbits twisting and coming
into the solar system and then we went
out and realized that those things exist
and that nobody else nobody had an
explanation for them they would they
would be found and people would just say
so weird I don't know why these things
are coming in and now so so our
hypothesis now explains you know the the
alignment some of the other detailed
dynamics these other objects were like
it's fitting together at that moment I
mean literally the moment we did that I
think both of us just kind of looked at
each other like oh oh there's actually
oh this there's a oh there's a planet
out there and it went from just you know
cute idea to holy cow there's a planet
let's go find it you're optimistic about
finding it you can buy find it we mean
literally yeah yes I mean in the end
it's a hypothesis that I am convinced is
true no one else need believe it until
we go see it
our people basically up to me
or people's coffee some of each there's
a whole group of people who are
desperately trying to find it because
they're convinced we had a we had a
workshop here at Caltech in late spring
of all the people around the globe who
are in search of it and exchanged ideas
and where we thought it was and how to
and who was searching and how they were
finding it but there are people who are
like so the there are the general
skeptics like I think most scientists
should be who probably not looked very
hard at the evidence you know until you
look at it really carefully you are your
default it's always gonna be come on the
planet and that's that's right that's
the way to be and then there are the no
way it's impossible I'm going to prove
you wrong and they try and yeah they
haven't I haven't succeeded yet but but
meanwhile you're flying to Hawaii going
up on top of the mountain yes big
telescope yes and taking snapshots and
yes to see a dot moving yeah it's what I
started in 1978 with photographic plates
and now we're we're continuing yet now
looking for something even more distant
and a lot fainter do you really have to
fly to Hawaii I mean don't they have
robots so depends on the telescope
actually so the telescope that we're
using the Subaru telescope on top of
Mauna Kea is the Japanese National
telescope and they require you to be
there they don't need to require you to
be there but but they do as a
philosophical dilemma of necessity and
it would be it would there's no actual
reason for us to be there it would it
would work just fine with us on video
link somewhere else and sometimes they
actually do do that but they do make us
come up there which I don't I don't mind
at all it's a spectacular place to go
when you see a moving dot how quickly
will you know and with what level of
certainty that it actually is the planet
you've been beautiful so I I think that
if I if we found a moving dot in the in
the Subaru Survey the things that you
want to know are how fast is it moving
because that tells you how far away it
is and how bright it is because that
tells you about how big it is basically
if we find anything that is five or six
or seven hundred au
way we we can't see things that far away
unless their planets basically so if we
see something moving at the predicted
speed and you know we won't see it that
night at the telescope we bring all the
data home and to have it cranked through
computer but it but AC I'll be sitting
my office I'll be looking through
candidates and one will come up and
it'll be consistent with everything and
I will be 98 percent certain at that
point very quickly really okay and so
but what we'll do one is all assume it's
real and I'll think about what I'm doing
about it but the other thing we'll do is
we'll very quickly predict where it
should be you know this will probably be
a week or two later it took us will
predict where it should be
that night based on what we did and we
will find some astronomer somewhere in
the world at some telescope and say go
take a picture right here and tell me
nothing to tell you why but no no it is
well there you know I have enough
friends who would it would do it and if
it's where we predict then it is 100% no
questions it is there we know it and
then the fun starts because finding it
is fun yeah but it's but it's actually
studying it and learning about this new
giant planet that you know we only have
four we got a new one yeah pretty cool
so we have we have our day zero things
that we want to do that we'll start
doing immediately well you know you
killed Pluto for which we can't really
forgive you but it will compensate
somewhat if you find another replacement
this is you know it was all suggested by
my daughter about four years ago she
said she said she said daddy do you know
how to get people to stop hating you I
was like gosh no I don't nobody knows
how should i do why is my four-year-old
daughter she said oh you should go find
a new planet and then people wouldn't
hate you anymore and I laughed and said
hahaha
but there's no new planets and now I
realize it was she she knew what she was
talking about alright well we are
rooting for you Mike Brown thanks so
much for coming on the plug it was fun
[Music]
you
[Music]